مسؤوليه الجيش الروسي في اداره الحرب في
اوكرانيا وصفا يفتقرون للدقه في الحقيقه
موسكو تشرف على العمليات القتاليه عبر
تحالفا للجيوش الموليه لها وبارنر اشهرها
لكنها اقلها عددا فماذا عن البقيه
البدايه من القوات الانفصاليه تقود الحرب
ضد كياب منذ ذراعيه حرب القرمه شهر ابريل
عام 2014 بلغت اعداد قواتها 50,000 مقاتله
وميزتها انها تحارب على ارضها فنفذ المهام
الاصعب على الارض وتكبدت حصه الاسد من
الخسائر البشريه تم حلها نظريا بعد ضم
روسيا للاقليم وهي الان الجيش منفصل
تابعون لي وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
المشهد هو الميدانيه في دومباز تجسيد واضح
لنظريه جراس موف عباره عن اتحاد فرق
عسكريه منفصله القياده روسيتش مثلا مجموعه
من النازيين الجدد في روسيا علاقتها
بفاكنر اقوى من انفصالي دوم بس تتخذوا من
جبهه خاركه مسرحا لعمليهاتها في حين
تلاحقها تهم جرائم حرب بحق السجناء
الاوكرانيين جيش اخر اقرب لوزاره الدفاع
الروسيه وهي القوات الخاصه الشيشانيه
ولائهم قبل الطبعه المطلق للرئيس رمضان
لكن ذلك لم يمنع تعاونهم مع الجيش
اوكرانيا واحده وعشرين الفا 9000 منهم على
الجبهه تحديدا في الجروبكا شمال
ينتقد بوضوح اداء جينيرالات جيرا سيموف
وفي وسطي دوم بس وبالتحديد في باخمه وعلى
محور السيفرست شمالا تتمركز باقلر قفزات
اعداد عناصرها مؤخرا الى بضعه الاف الى من
قطعه الاف الى 10% من تعداد القوات
الروسيه في اوكرانيا هدفهم هو السيطره
الكامله على دومبرز بما كذلك رمث
صراع بين مختلف هياكل القوه الروسيه بعد
على الساحه الان في العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه وبحسب خبر عسكريين صراع خفيف قد
يكون بين قائد فاذر من جهه ووزاره الدفاع
الروسيه من جهه اخرى
عدم الزهور لكنه مؤخرا استحوذ على الاضواء
بظهوره المتكرر
وبمشاركه فاكنر اكثر في الحرب وتحديدا في
ضخمه وسوليدار اما قائد العمليات العسكريه
الجديد دراسه موف فلديه استراتيجيه جديده
على الارض اولا تسريع عمليه اتخاذ القرار
العسكري لان الظروف كان لم يتمكن من
اصداره اوامر مباشره للاسطول او للطيران
بعيد المدى ثانيا امكانيه استخدام مجموعه
واسعه من الاسلحه المختلفه لضرب القوات
الاخرانيه ومن بينها الاسلحه النوويه